nouveauté cette année pour les lycéens
parcours suprend place à pbd ce 22
janvier les élèves doivent maintenant
formulé dit veut mais sans les
hiérarchiser comme avant au salon de
l'étudiant de versailles ces changements
ne sont pas encore tout à fait clair
pour certains l'arrêt parle c'est fait
c'est décider rapidement et assez
tardivement et effectivement les jeunes
sont inquiets on peut tout à fait
comprendre les parents s'inquiètent
beaucoup de la procédure préalable c'est
à dire de l'inscription comment est ce
qu'on fait pour s'inscrire
comment est ce qu'on fait pour choisir
les voeux avant mais il ne s'inquiète
relativement peu de la procédure après
quand ils auront la réponse une nouvelle
plateforme censée simplifier les
démarches
le salon de l'étudiant de versailles
accompagne les lycéens dans leurs
recherches ils peuvent aussi compter sur
leur rétablissement pour être rassurés
n'a une initiation à parcours superbe à
s'inscrire avec les processeurs on a des
accompagnements personnalisés
réservé à l'orientation à la
préservation des écoles à la
présentation du parcours sup pour qu'on
puisse apprendre et connaître mieux la
plateforme dans son ensemble alain minc
est forcément un peu après je l'essaie
de faire de tout faire pour
à la fin les futurs étudiants ont
jusqu'au 13 mars pour saisir leurs voeux
sur parcours sup peut être de nouveaux
arrivants fouleront les bancs des écoles
et universités de saint quentin en
yvelines
chaque année l'agglomération accueille
plus de 18 mille étudiants